[Music]
all right hello everyone perfect how's
everyone doing this afternoon
great welcome to hybrid 200 securing
kubernetes secrets
my name is Seth I'm a developer advocate
I work on the developer relations here
team here at Google
hi I'm Alex share nikolsky I'm a
security engineer at Google working on
Google Keeper native sangeun security
team great
so everyone clap for Alex he's gonna
leave the stage now he's gonna come back
in a little bit and show us some really
cool live demos who's excited the rest
of you don't like live demos great so in
order to set some common ground I know
some of you are probably security
professionals this might seem a little
bit repetitive but I want to make sure
that everyone is on the same page so I
want to start by talking and answering a
very simple question what is a secret so
for the purpose of this talk a secret is
a credential a configuration an API key
or some other piece of information that
is required for an application either at
Build time or at runtime so some
examples here might be like a database
username and password a Twitter API key
any type of secret or sensitive
information that the application needs
to run and that begs the next question
which is why do we care why should we
just not use social media as our secrets
management tool why don't you store your
secrets and publicly available tweets
well it turns out that secrets are an
attractive target for attackers secrets
often protect sensitive information like
personally identifiable information
credit card numbers social security
numbers passport numbers or they protect
access to business data business
intelligence data like analytics and
reports that could damage your business
or give your competitors an advantage
but then you couple that with how easily
credentials are leaked if we look at any
of the recent security incidents we've
seen you know access keys leaked in a
public dinner we're posit Ori
because of a small mistake from a
developer we've seen you know improperly
secured access to a dashboard or an
interface allowing privilege escalation
it's very easy for us to leak these
credentials and expose secrets
unintentionally and then third most
secrets actually have more permission
than they need particularly when we're
talking about
I am credentials or identity and access
management credentials and that's
because when you're a large startup it's
just much easier to give everyone root
access because I don't know what they're
gonna need in a week or two right I
don't want to have to go through that I
need to move quickly and then oftentimes
security is an afterthought so when you
combine these three things we have
something that accesses customer data or
business data that's easily leaked and
has overly broad permissions
it's an attackers like best playground
so this is why we need to invest effort
in protecting our secrets and there are
four key ways in which we protect
secrets today the first is auditing we
verify all of the use and access of
individual secrets in some type of
centralized system this allows us to
apply anomaly detection or machine
learning to find out whenever a secret
is being accessed out of the norm
second we use encryption all of our data
should be encrypted in transit with TLS
and it rest with the most secure
algorithm for your use case and your
industry third we should be rotating
both secrets and encryption keys
regularly in addition to a regular
schedule of rotation we need a break
glass procedure
what happens if right now we leak a
credential how quickly can we rotate
that credential across our
infrastructure right now we leak an API
key how quickly can we revoke and
replace that API key so we need both
planned rotation which decreases our
surface area for an attack and we need
immediate rotation in the event of an
emergency and fourth isolation is key we
want to separate where secrets are
stored
from where secrets are accessed that way
an attacker has to compromise multiple
systems and escalate privilege multiple
times in order to gain access to that
plaintext information for the purposes
of this talk we're going to be focusing
on that second component specifically
encryption now that doesn't mean that
the other three are less important but I
only have 40 minutes so we're gonna
focus on encryption there are multiple
layers of encryption you might have
things like encrypted file systems like
File Vault self encrypting hard drives
etc but you might also have say machine
level encryption or service level
encryption or a player encryption and we
recommend that you always use at least
two layers of encryption for your data
now on Google Cloud all of your data is
encrypted at rest by default no
configuration necessary but you may want
to apply additional layers of encryption
to your data specifically you may want
to leverage application layer encryption
application layer encryption is applied
at one of the earliest possible stages
of the data's lifecycle secrets are
encrypted before they leave your
application or service with keys or
encryption tokens that only your
application notes so in this way only
your application or only the critical
components of your system see the
plaintext value this enables very
granular protection of data you can use
a different encryption key for each
piece of customer data that way if an
attacker is able to brute-force that
encryption key or the decryption key
that same key will not work for another
piece of customer data and third this
protects the data as it moves throughout
the system so if I have a hard drive and
that hard drive is encrypted if I mount
that hard drive and decrypt it somewhere
if an attacker has access to that hard
drive they have access to all of the
plaintext data now but by a leveraging
application layer encryption as I move
my secret data throughout the system it
remains encrypted regardless of the
underlying storage mechanism whether
that's memory a hard disk or a thumb
drive in the context of kubernetes
application
encryption means that the kubernetes api
server is responsible for performing the
crypto operations so in addition to your
application your pod your service the
kubernetes api server also has
privileged to see those plaintext
secrets and we advocate for
defense-in-depth again use multiple
layers of encryption use application
layer encryption combined with operating
system layer encryption things like
secure boot and hard drive encryption
etc so now let's talk about kubernetes
the kubernetes default installation is
not encrypted by default so today if you
were to download the open source
distribution of kubernetes and start up
a kubernetes cluster regardless of cloud
provider regardless of infrastructure
the underlying secrets are not encrypted
that means that anyone who has access to
at CD or a backup of s CD has access to
all of your plaintext since all of your
secrets in plaintext
let me show you what that looks like
here I have a credit card or a piece of
data I'm using this image to show that
this is a secret as a user or as an
application I give that piece of secret
data to the kubernetes api server when I
say coop cuttle create secret or The
Associated API call the kubernetes api
server then base64 encode that data and
writes it to etsy d I saw someone smile
they got my base64 joke so the app
submits the secret to kubernetes the API
server pushes that into Etsy D into
plain text that means that if an
attacker has access to the master node
an online Etsy d server or a backup of
the SED database all of your kubernetes
secrets are available in plain text
again this is a default kubernetes
installation regardless of cloud
regardless of infrastructure the open
source distro out-of-the-box this is
called encryption
in Crafton is what happens when you
confuse encryption with encoding so and
my goal here is like not to make fun of
kubernetes right kubernetes is an
amazing product and they've made great
strides to improve the overall security
so while this is the default setup let's
talk about just how easy it is to
extract secrets and then I'll talk about
some of the improvements that kubernetes
has made to make it easier to secure
your secrets so if we could jump over to
the screen while you're ahead of me
perfect and now I pull out my cheat
sheet because because I'm only human all
right so what I have here is I'm using a
mini cube which is just a local
kubernetes cluster and I have the base
default installation of the latest
version of kubernetes and what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to go into this
folder and then I'm going to show you
the command that I'm going to be running
here so I'm going to create a secret I'm
going to use this default cluster that
I've created and then I'm going to
create a secret where I have a key value
pair the user name is Seth Fargo and the
password is very secure secret and
leet-speak so let me go ahead and run
this now will run pin create secret
default and now I've created that secret
so as I was showing before this is a
default kubernetes setup which means
it's stored a net CD in plaintext so let
me show you what that looks like if I
access the default secret now you'll
notice that I get back some additional
metadata here right I get I get back
almost like a binary representation
there's some additional metadata in here
but most importantly right there as I've
highlighted on the screen that's the
plain text password that's the plain
text username all of that information
that I supplied is in plain text a net
CD very easy for an attacker to extract
that information and escalate a
privilege in my system
so let's go ahead and jump back to the
slides now perfect
now before we talk about some of the
improvements that kubernetes has made
let's talk about this concept called
envelope encryption because it's very
important because it's the underlying
principle for how kubernetes secrets
encryption works so envelope encryption
is this idea of keys all the way down or
Turtles all the way down if you will
there are three pieces that we're gonna
talk about here today again we have our
data which is represented by this kind
of credit card icon we have a data
encryption key or a deck represented by
a red key and we have a key encryption
key or a keck represented by a green key
now when we want to encrypt data we take
the data encryption key of the red team
and we encrypt the data so we generate a
key and we encrypt the data with that
key and that produces encrypted data
that is encrypted with our red key our
data encryption key then we take our key
encryption key and we encrypt our data
encryption key so you'll notice here on
the slide I have the credit card which
is encrypted with the red key and then I
have the data encryption key which is
encrypted with the green key encryption
key we then take both of those pieces of
data and we put them together
implementation details aside and we
store them side-by-side and in some type
of storage back-end filesystem database
whatever it might be and the idea here
is that each piece of data has its own
encryption key we generate a new red key
a new data encryption key for each piece
of data and that that data is maintained
by is encrypted by a key encryption key
which has its own rotation schedule when
we want to reverse the process the
encrypted blob is separated into its two
parts again implementation details the
key encryption key decrypt the data
encryption key bits that then gives us
the plaintext
data encryption key we then take the
plaintext data encryption key and
decrypt the remaining bits to give us
back the original plaintext data this is
a very rudimentary and very quick
overview of how envelope encryption
works
the key here is y'all are not up for
jokes it's fun the key here is that each
new piece of data is encrypted with a
new unique randomly generated key and
then we have a regular rotation
scheduled for our key encryption keys so
maybe that's monthly or weekly or
quarterly depending on your threat model
and your requirements so there are some
best practices for envelope encryption
we want to generate unique data
encryption keys so each piece of data is
encrypted with its own high entropy
unique key this allows us to do really
cool things like crypto struttin so if
we were a VOC our key encryption key
that top-level key all of the data
encryption keys are now irrecoverable by
traditional means because they were
encrypted with that key additionally we
can rotate our key encryption keys on
time-based intervals or in the event of
an emergency while we rotate the data
encryption keys each time we modify the
data so this provides a very scalable
way to do cryptographic operations so
now let's go back to kubernetes so
kubernetes 1.7 made its first attempt at
solving this problem by introducing a
new configuration option for encrypting
secrets at rest before they enter at CD
and that looks like this so this is what
we call an encryption configuration and
you'll notice inside this encryption
configuration I'm specifying an
encryption provider in this example it's
an aes CBC provider and I'm giving it
the base64 encoded encryption key I take
this encryption configuration it's a
yamo file I load it onto my master node
or my crib minetti's API server I then
start or restart my kubernetes api
server by passing in this encryption
provider configuration option I give it
the path to that yellow file and now
we're good to go so let me show you what
this looks like in this new model so
going back to our original diagram I
have my credit card my secret data I
give that to the kubernetes api server
again the kubernetes api server does
see the plaintext here but the
kubernetes api server then delegates to
that encryption provider configuration
the encryption provider configuration
encrypts the data before writing it to
NCD so we have random bytes of data in
NCD so this means if an attacker had
access to an online @ çd database or a
backup of the SED database they would
not be able to recover the plaintext by
traditional means but what if an
attacker had access to the master VM a
full disk backup of the master node or
the kubernetes api server well if an
attacker has access to that that
encryption configuration is on that same
node in a file it's in that yellow file
that I showed earlier so if an attacker
is able to gain access to the VM they
have access to the keys then encrypted
the data and you haven't actually
improved your security posture so from a
threat modeling perspective this
actually wasn't any better but it was a
step in the right direction because now
the community started thinking hey we
should actually be encrypting our
secrets and this is the way that we
should do it so there are a number of
drawbacks with this approach the first
you have to generate your own keys you
need your own high entropy source you
need to understand key algorithms you
need to understand what is it like what
are you gonna use you're gonna use CBC
or you're gonna use GCM what type of key
do you want after you create those keys
you then need to manage them you need to
set up your own rotation schedule you
need to set up your own revocation
schedule you need to be responsible for
making sure that they're always online
and each time you update those keys you
have to restart your kubernetes api
server potentially causing downtime as I
said you have to rotate them on your own
you have to update that config and if
you're trying to get rid of old
encryption keys you actually have to
re-encrypt all of your secrets another
drawback is that many of you might be in
organizations or regulatory requirements
where you're relying on HSMs to achieve
PCI or HIPAA compliance and there's no
way with the kubernetes 1.7 encryption
provider configuration to leverage a
hardware
module you can't can't leverage an HSM
so that was kind of a non-starter for
some of those customers who are
depending on that and most importantly
as they already said the biggest
drawback is that those encryption keys
are stored in plain text in the file
system so from a threat modeling
perspective we haven't actually
increased our security posturing by very
much the keys are still available in
plain text and because the attacker
could just get the keys and decrypt the
data it's effectively a no event
operation to get the plain text data out
of a CD so kubernetes 1.10 provides a
much more secure solution using a new
kind of secrets provider KMS in this
model kubernetes delegates encryption to
a third-party kms provider like Google
Cloud km/s or Hasek or vault so let me
show you what that looks like again it's
the same encryption configuration but
instead of specifying the keys directly
in this encryption configuration which
lives on disk we instead specify the
plug-in and the eunich socket where that
plug-in resides we load that up the same
way that we did before but now there's a
third party system in our flow we have
our secret data our secret data goes to
the API server the API server hits the
encryption configuration the encryption
configuration then makes a UNIX socket
call to in the case of Google Cloud kms
the Google Cloud ap is to encrypt or
decrypt this data Google Cloud kms then
returns encrypted cipher text which is
then stored in sed so even if an
attacker has access to the master nodes
those encryption keys are maintained by
an external system an attacker would
have to compromise both the master nodes
at CD and the third-party kms system in
order to be able to decrypt those values
offline but that might sound complicated
right like that's a lot of things and
that interaction with UNIX sockets and
file permissions that sounds difficult
but the community has already built of
of these for us so there's an
open-source google cloud KMS plugin that
Alex actually worked on he's going to
talk a little bit about it in a second
there's one for Usher
there's one for AWS and there's one for
a hex record vault so the communities
and the various special interest groups
are working hard to make sure that your
favorite secrets management solutions
and your favorite kms providers are
supported as external kms plug-ins for
kubernetes now if you are on Google
Cloud specifically we actually just
launched a feature into beta that does
all of this for you it is so easy that I
actually thought the PM was lying to me
when she showed it to me I was like it
just can't be this easy Maya there's no
way but it actually is just this easy so
this is a g-cloud command there's an
Associated API call you have three
pieces of information when you create
your cluster you give it the KMS key
location the KMS key ring and the KMS
key you're telling g ke the google
kubernetes engine please encrypt my
secrets with this cloud KMS key and all
of that set up and all of those things I
showed you before that's all done for
you automatically
but this begs an interesting question
which is how does kubernetes get
permission to talk to the kms provider
in the first place there has to be some
exchange on asset authentication and
this is where cloud providers have an
advantage because cloud providers offer
Identity and Access Management as a
first-class part of their product
portfolio so iam solves that first
secret problem or the last mile problem
we delegate privilege and access
management to the cloud providers I am
and then we have a nice separation of
concerns the sed nodes don't need I am
permission to talk to kms so even if
someone has access to the VM on which
Etsy D is running they don't have
permission to talk to cloud kms because
itd doesn't need that only the
kubernetes api server does so with that
I'd like to invite Alex back on stage to
talk a little bit about how this works
under the hood on gke and the way that
we do application layer encryption so
please give it up for Alex
Thank You self so stuff is very
convincing so I think my I don't even
think I need to be here anymore but I
guess I need to prove something that it
actually works so I'm hoping that by
this point in the presentation you're
reasonably convinced that storing
secrets in plain texts in scg even
though the underlying disk is encrypted
may not be the best security posture for
your organization and you're wondering
how do I enable this additional layer of
encryption or additional layer of
protection when I'm running kubernetes
in google cuban education so I will show
this in this demo it's a two-step
process the first step is we need to
create cryptographic keys we need to
create cryptographic keys and cloud kms
you will find you will find
cryptographic keys in the security
subsection of Google cloud platform when
you land there you will notice there is
a concept of key rings that is
introduced by cloud KMS key rings are
analogous to directories in a file
system you can group together logically
related keys and for example apply I am
policy at the keyring level as opposed
to managing individual keys what you
will also know what is is that key rings
allocation specific they attach the
specific location and why it is
important point for us to know because
our kubernetes cluster will need to
communicate with cloud kms and basically
whenever and we want that connection to
be as quick as possible so you want to
koala kate your kubernetes clusters and
you are
Claudia mask is in the same region ok so
let me create a key let's try to find a
meaningful name
and you know what the defaults will
actually are just fine for us before I
could create the only thing I will point
out to make the previous discussion
about key rotation a little bit more
concrete is this parameter here rotation
period which is by default 90 days but
you can see that you can set it to
whatever makes sense to your
organization okay so let me go ahead and
click create
alright so that takes care of the
prerequisite work and now I'm ready to
switch to kubernetes engine and I will
create my cluster in order to enable
this fishery we need to expand
availability networking security and
additional features section and I need
to scroll down to security subsection
and check enable application layer
encryption so just a quick note on
terminology in this talk we use the term
at CD level encryption quite a bit and I
think it's a very pragmatic way of
thinking about it but the reality is
that HCD is an implementation detail in
cuber Nettie's kubernetes
is designed to be agnostic to the
configuration database so for that
reason we decided to have a more generic
name for this feature so hopefully this
will help you when you're reading
documentation on the feature you will
see the term application layer
encryption as opposed to as opposed to a
CD level encryption so now that I check
this option you can see that the UI team
has done a great job and what the UI has
done for me in the background it
enumerated all the keys in that project
that meet the requirements for this
feature so I only have one so I'll go
ahead and select that
and this is another interesting thing is
that I get a warning here that sam-i-am
permissions are missing on the key
enable explain what those I am
permissions are and why do we need them
when we go back to the slides but for
now just say that the
bernetta service Asian account needs
encrypt decree privileges on those keys
and I have this all I need to do is just
click this grant button and that problem
is now resolved all that I need to do
now at this point is just hit create so
and while the cluster is spinning up I
would like to switch back to the slide
and talk about the feature under the
hood a little bit thank you so let's
review the components involved let's
review the components involved in the
encryption process however this time
we'll go over throws components from the
threat modeling point of view to better
reason about the threat model we will
classify components involved as either
volatile everything above the dotted
line or persistence and if everything
below the line so the the persistent
resources we assume we assume that
attackers have full access to anything
on the persistent drive for the sake of
argument let's assume that attackers
were able to get a copy of the object
uber name is master VM of course the
main point of interest for us is the sed
data file however we are not limited we
are not assuming that attackers have
access only to the HDD data file
anything on that persistent drive which
may help attackers to decrypt secrets
also a fair game we need to protect
against those scenarios so this
introduces the what I call last mile
problem and Steph mentioned self calls
at the first secret problem but they all
point to the same thing when you look at
the diagram it becomes fairly obvious
that kms plugin needs to authenticate to
cloud kmf service so this implies that
came as plugin needs to have some sort
of credential in order to negotiate an
AW stalkin to present o´clock EMS
like like pretty much everything else in
Google cloud we use OAuth protocol in
order to for authentication purposes so
what if an attacker what if we persisted
that credential or the resulting talking
to disk well in this case attackers
would actually have everything they need
in order to decrypt our secrets because
they have access to the protected ICD
data file but they also have a talkin or
it's credential to speak to cloud kms
and cloud commands by virtue of being a
cloud service obviously is accessible
over public internet so it's important
to make sure that we are not leaking
well I'm jumping ahead sorry so the core
design objective is to ensure in our
threat model that attackers it is okay
for attackers to have access to the SED
data file but they should not have
access to anything else that would allow
them to bootstrap communication with the
cloud kms and in the next several slides
I will explain how we map this objective
this will be a review for most of you
but I wanted to make sure that we are on
the same page and I wanted to explain
some concepts about Jiki most of you
probably already know this but let
please whistle on me a couple of minutes
here so you probably already know that
Google handles all of the details of
running kubernetes masters kubernetes
masters reside in Google managed
infrastructure in Google managed
projects however a less known fact is
that when you enable GCE API in your
project a service account which we refer
to as kubernetes ask you donated Service
agent account is created somewhere else
in Google manage infrastructure and that
service account is granted some ie and
privileges in the customer project well
why well when we think about the process
of creating a cluster Jiki needs to
perform operations such as create a
virtual machine create a firewall rule
create a persistent disk obviously all
of these operations require security con
and yes it is through this service
account that Jiki accesses resources in
your customer projects okay so that was
just a review to set the plane for the
next discussion so what about cloud KMS
keys how do we access those well you saw
in the demo that the expectation is that
you customers create those keys ahead of
time and you grant the encrypt decrypt
privileges on those keys - kubernetes
service asian account you saw me just
clicking that button and the UI fixed
that for me that was kind of magic but
you can certainly do this in a different
ways for example you can go into the
cloud kms UI and just use I am and grant
permissions there or you can use g-cloud
commands you may be thinking that was
very simple up that was a very simple
operation to create that key why
couldn't you just embed this into the
classic creation process well we
certainly consider doing this but
decided against this we felt that giving
G key the ability to create this very
security sensitive artifacts in your
projects would give G key away too much
power and we also felt that that would
break the segmentation between G key and
cloud kms therefore we expect the two
customers create those keys and allow us
G key to use them for the purposes of
this feature the remaining piece of the
puzzle hard as cloud had a scheme as
plugin actually authenticate to cloud
came a service so this is done by
communicating with an internal talking
service which is again managed by Google
and the internal internal talking
service requires kms plug-in to prove
that it is a member of a cluster that is
linked to the corresponding service
account so for example trying to
negotiate access to cryptic key not me
the cloud cam has try to negotiate
access to that crypto key and what
talking service will try to figure out
are you in fact running on that cluster
that is linked to that service account
the cubanía service asian account and if
you can prove this to me
then I will give you that token so we
don't have time to go through the proof
of membership protocol here but it is
sufficient to say that the stalking
service has full knowledge about the
master components and it can make that
decision of whether a granting were
denying the access based on the prior
information in the database that it has
access to so assuming that everything
went fine talking service was satisfied
with the fact that kms plugin runs in
the right cluster it will grant this
auth token wishes now TMS can present to
the encrypt or decrypt history it can
present to the cloud EMS service this
token service this this auth token is
not persisted to disk we store it in
memory and we if the kms plugin is
rebooted we'll just go through the same
dance once once again but at no uptime
we actually store it to disk and that is
how we actually and that is how we met
our initial objective we do not store
credentials on disk and we do not store
the resulting tokens to disk which
allows us to meet our threat model where
all that occurs get is just at CD with
encrypted with encrypted secrets ok this
is my last slide and I'm going to change
the subject just a little bit and I want
to talk about how to run cloud kms
plug-in outside G key so even though we
hope that you use in G key to run
kubernetes we understand that some of
you may be using Google compute engine
VMs as the infrastructure to run
kubernetes and the question is can we
achieve the same security contract when
running outside Jiki and the answer is
yes it just simply the caches that are
simply more work to manage and set it up
clock MS plugin is developed in open
source you have a link here to the
repository and in the same repository
you will find instructions on how to set
up cloud KMS plug-in out
like you were natives when running on GC
architectural it looks very similar the
core difference being of course that
there is no kubernetes Service agent
account instead we rely on the service
account in in the security context of
which runs the GC VM you probably know
that when you create a GC VM you can
associate it with a service account and
by virtue of this association GC VM can
impersonate that service account so you
pretty much followed the same process
you create a service account you create
keys your grant service account encrypt
decree privileges on the key and then
you start the GC BM in the security
context of that of that service account
from that point on everything looks the
same but there's just a little bit more
work and then you have to manage manage
it from that point on this is all ahead
was that I would like to invite self
back on stage thank you all right thank
you Alex but you work on security right
yeah so there's one thing that I learned
is that you never trust someone who
works on security products so how do we
know you just didn't fake that gke thing
like how do we know that application
layer encryption is even enabled on that
oh you mean like the cluster actually
failed to create an something and they
just didn't show that yeah like that
could've been a recording for all we
know right could we switch to the demo
again all right so the cluster did
create okay so which is a good sign
all right but on the serious note that
was the cluster that we created a few
minutes ago so what is the visual
indication that you have a cluster with
that feature enabled so if you scroll
down a little bit you will see
application layer encryption and you can
see it's enabled and here again you have
a link if I follow this link it should
take me to the cryptographic key that we
created as in the first step and here's
where you can manage the key like for
example the options available to me are
disabled destroy
and Zeff talked about crypto shredding
if I wanted to kill that cluster right
now all I need to do is just destroy
that key and essentially it will not be
possible to create new secrets on that
cluster which I'm not sure if I
recommend this option I would probably
just delete the cluster in the first
place but it is something that you need
to be aware of anyways I think you'd
approve it enough I do I have another
question for you though I'm gonna put
you on the spot what if I have an
existing cluster how can I enable this
on an existing cluster yes version
specific though
okay so need to we needed we were
waiting for some updates in queue burn
areas 113 we should allow us to enable
encryption on existing clusters okay so
as long as they're running kubernetes
version 113 or later you can enable this
on an exam is correct super cool thanks
Alex if we go back to the slides please
so we know that many of you might be on
Prem you might be on another cloud
provider you might be doing all of those
things and you may already be using a
secrets management tool like Hasek or
vault so what if you're not on a cloud
provided kubernetes service what if
you're not on gke what if you're not
entirely on gke how can you protect
yourself against you know these types of
attacks where an attacker has access to
the at CD backup or an online at CD
database so you can leverage something
like Hasek or vault to do this and it
looks very similar to what we already
described so instead of Google Cloud kms
we throw hash tag or a vault in the mix
specifically we're using hashing or
vaults cloud transit back-end transit
secrets engine if you will the secret
engine is very similar to a cloud kms
provider it has key management rotation
upgrading downgrading etc it looks very
similar to what we described before the
secret data is given to the kubernetes
api server the kubernetes api server
then delegates to the encryption
configuration the encryption
configuration then makes an API call to
something like Hasek or vault the vault
transit back in encrypts that data or
decrypt that data before it is written
back to at CD so this is a great
opportunity if you have multi cloud
strata
if you're leveraging you know multiple
clouds multiple Nettie's clusters this
gives you a very consistent way in order
to encrypt your secrets with an existing
secrets management solution so very
quickly I'd like to show you what that
looks like and show you what the data in
sed looks like if it's encrypted with
something like hash record vault or
Google cloud kms can we jump over to the
laptop e please cool so what I'm gonna
do here is create secret vault
so I have a mini cube cluster the same
one I had before but this time I added
an encryption provider configuration to
encrypt secrets with hasha core vault
before writing them to NCD I could have
done this Google Cod kms or even another
cloud providers kms but I'm using vault
locally to showcase kind of a
third-party open source tool now I'm
gonna go ahead and try to access that
secret and you'll notice that we don't
get back to the plaintext data so even
though I had the same secret username
South Fargo a password secret and leet
this is what I get back I get back
kubernetes encryption prefix the vault
key that I'm using and then a bunch of
data that my terminal can't even print
for you so if an attacker has access to
ED CD or has access to this plaintext
data this this is what they would get
right they won't they don't get the
plaintext secrets they get this
encrypted data and again this example
here shows what it looks like on high
score vaults
if on Google Cloud you had access to the
underlying SED data it would look very
similar to this if you were using
application layer encryption then if the
plaintext data would not be available to
you so we jump back to the slides real
quick so to conclude kubernetes 1.10 and
later introduce some really great
features that make it easy to be secure
with kubernetes secrets always use
layered encryption useful disk
encryption operating system encryption
combined with something like application
layer encryption rotate your keys
regularly both on a schedule and in the
event of a data breach leverage envelope
encryption it's an incredibly scalable
way to perform encryption and fourth use
an external kms provider whether
something like google cloud KMS or
something like Hasek or volts as it
requires an attacker to compromise
multiple systems in order to gain access
to that plaintext data
[Music]